you remember how he said things want to
keep doing whatever they're doing if
they're at rest they want to stay at
rest
if they're moving in uniform straight
line motion they want to keep doing that
well turns out some things are more
determined to do that
than others some things want to stay put
more than others and it's harder to get
them to move right
and that determination how much
something wants to stay doing that we
call
mass right now mass is usually defined
as how much
stuff is there somewhere okay but if
there's more stuff
then there's also more resistance to
being moved i don't want to go anywhere
and you'll have to try a lot harder to
do it right so um
everything wants to keep doing what it's
doing some things want to keep doing it
more than others
and that means they've got more mass
okay
now there's a lot of implications to
this for instance
if you've got the same force right
acting on two objects which have
different masses right
same force so this is mutants okay
and you've got a light object
and a heavy object an
object with not much mass and a lot
right
this guy's not putting up much of a
fight right whereas this guy is
so you're going to get different
accelerations
as a result
okay different accelerations now come
back to those up to the table that we
did
right and we had this right down the
bottom right or pretty much
down the bottom okay f equals m a
so let's consider an actual example um a
specific amount of force so i'll call it
f1
so it's a constant okay then i've got a
specific
object right so it has a specific kind
of mass
and then i've got a specific
acceleration that results from that
okay now if i choose a different object
that has a different kind of
mass then a different acceleration will
result
right now just look at this for a second
because everything here is constant
right i could take something like this
out of the equation and it would still
be true
right it's just for a specific value now
have a look at this there's some insight
in here if we rearrange it
for instance if i divide both sides
through a little bit
right for example do this
it's the same equation but it tells you
something different
right have a look think about this
the ratio between these two masses right
for example suppose
this was the heavier object and this is
the lighter one
more mass here less mass here okay
what does it mean for these guys right
well these two
quantities are inversely proportional
can you see that
right as i make one object heavier right
it's going to accelerate less so that's
what you get from these two ratios
and it's exactly equal okay different
accelerations but it's not just random
it's not just arbitrary
okay so
oh yeah um you can think about this not
just from
this kind of point of view but think
about it like this
um i wrote this right
okay now let's just suppose the mass
actually let's just
make that a variable who knows what it
is okay so
if i now do a similar thing over here
and divide through if i have something
like this
constant force okay some mass that i
don't know you decide what you want
okay and then the acceleration that
results
can you see what's going to happen as i
vary m
you see what's going to happen if this
force is some constant
and i make m super small very light
object
okay what happens to acceleration
it increases right because when you make
the denominator of a fraction
small you make the whole thing big and
vice versa if you made something
astronomically heavy
like literally astronomically heavy okay
then
it takes up you know this same force is
going to hardly make it budge at all
does that make sense so you can see how
we're digging more into the equations
than what they mean than just okay can
you use it and punch stuff into it
right